okay so we've been to i don't want to
spend a lot of time on this but this
this is uh
important it's newsworthy um we've been
talking about what is 2022 going to look
like
to what degree will the republican party
lean towards trumpism in 2022
or against from trumpism in 2022. if you
look at the polling so far
trump's popular with most republican
voters
the republican electorate seems to have
no real desire for
policy being a thing that plays a
prominent role
in republican politics going into 2022
so trump plans to play king maker
and he may well get away with it and the
news now is that donald trump is again
going back to rallies
upcoming trump rallies max burns says
that the upcoming trump rallies
will help democrats remind voters why
they didn't re-elect him that's a very
optimistic perspective on these rallies
uh max burns writes this summer doesn't
mark
only the return of family get-togethers
in concerts
starting this month donald trump will
also be back in public circulation
headlining a series of grievance-filled
summer maga rallies and max says that
that's great news for anxious democrats
the return of trump's hours-long
rambling rallies is an opportunity to
remind the american people that
republican craziness hasn't dialed down
a notch
since his defeat last year and to remind
democrats
that they have reason to focus on their
shared values
rather than their increasingly bitter
senate fights
max burns goes on to say by now most
americans know
to expect plenty of disinformation and
far-right red meat from trump rallies
but they have yet to see how a
humiliating
electoral loss and trump's delusional
claim that he's about to be reinstated
as president any day now
mix with tried and true trump classics
like spreading election disinformation
and whining about cancel culture
after just one trump rally democrats
will have plenty of sound bites and
offensive content to make the case
that trump has learned nothing during
his time out of office surrounded by yes
men at mar-a-lago
and while trump's unhinged claims to be
the president of the united states in
exile
may energize mega fundamentalists they
reaffirm to independents and moderates
who rejected trump
that he has if anything grown more
detached from reality
in defeat i don't know that i'm as
optimistic as max burns
because what you have to remember is
that turnout
in general is down in midterms and so i
would expect
that neither democrats nor republicans
would see the turnout that they saw in
the 2020 presidential election
if democrats see unhinged
trump rallies maybe some of them who
wouldn't ordinarily vote in a midterm
might get out and vote but it's really
the republicans
who have been so deflated by this loss
who stand to gain from seeing trump
continuing to keep going
flying around the country supporting
marjorie taylor greene
supporting this person that person
whoever the case may be so for me it's
not as clear i mean yeah
trump will do the rallies and they'll be
insane and they'll be unhinged and
they'll be depraved and he'll tell
corrosive lies about american democracy
for sure
but it seems to me that there is much
more for republicans to gain
than what there is for democrats to gain
from it and there's one other thing and
i think this this is just a real fear
that i have and i know many in the
audience share it because they email me
uh about it um i think that the impact
of these rallies that trump will start
reportedly as soon as this month
may well incite trump's supporters
to be predisposed to more violence to
another insurrection attempt
to widespread violence against you know
whoever they perceive to be their enemy
on the left
and if you combine trump rallies in june
and july with trump reportedly starting
to say he will be reinstated as
president in august
and then when that doesn't happen i'm
worried about another january 6th and i
know that
there's it's becoming very um what's the
term
there's this term enlightened centrist
that i sometimes use i want to introduce
a new term now
there is a sort of um oh what how could
i how could i describe it and
it's almost like uh
a calm
concocted de-escalation
that people hear this stuff and they say
that's alarmist
let's all calm down we're not going to
see this and we're not going to see that
and we're not going to see another
january 6th
at this point anybody who is called an
alarmist simply for saying trump
saying stuff publicly could lead people
to violence
should just point to january 6th and
they're not even hiding their desire for
a coup at this point in time
um and there is a real a possibility and
these are people with a propensity to
violence we know that now there's no
question
look at the what is it 400 defendants in
the january 6th riot
related cases so i think there's a real
possibility
that not only do these trump rallies
inspire
more republicans to get out and vote in
2022 if trump keeps them going of course
then they will inspire democrats to get
out and vote it also has the possibility
of re
leading to to actual violence and that's
a really really scary thing
um just a couple other things that max
burns uh
writes um
[Music]
max burns writes indeed trump's return
to the political stage give democrats a
rare opportunity to set aside the
disagreements that come from governing
justice biden's honeymoon period is
ending
despite growing in patience among
progressives at the obstructionist
tactics displayed by democratic senators
kirsten cinema
of arizona and joe manchin of west
virginia trump's summer tour
will be a bracing reminder that things
could be far
worse i think that's probably the best
point max burns makes in this piece
which is you were starting to see more
and more
uh angry democrats and people on the
left saying biden should have already
done this
and biden should have already done that
and why he's doing this and where's the
public option
those are fair criticisms of joe biden
and i've participated in making many of
them
myself but i'm not losing sight of the
bigger picture here which is remember
what we had the last four years
the one thing that these trump rallies
coming back could do
is remind us of the craziness
that was a trump in comparison to
biden hasn't yet done everything he
promised to and it may sort of be
uniting for the left i think that that
is plausible
but i do think that the trump rally
leads for uh points to
much more to gain for republicans than
for democrats if you disagree if you
agree with max burns's take
that these trump rallies will just be
great for democrats going into 2022
i want to hear from you i just don't see
it